this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks everyone I really appreciate the
invitation to talk with you today what
I'd like to focus on is mitigating
wildlife damage and cropping systems and
I'll talk about some basic principles a
wildlife damage management whether
you're dealing with birds and mammals I
also want to go through results of a
survey we had a few years ago to give
you a sense of the magnitude of the
impacts that dear another wildlife cause
in New York State so we'll dive right
into it I think dennis late summarize
integrated wildlife damage management
pretty clearly and a conference several
years ago and it comes down to a very
simple process you can kill them you can
scare them you can put up a barrier or
you can spray a chemical that may or may
not work that's integrated wildlife
damage management now we can all go home
so but it's really you don't have a lot
of options when you're dealing with most
of these critters and they can cause
significant economic impacts there are
some keys I've seen over the years a
multiple species multiple cropping
system that tend to lead to success and
an integrated wildlife management
program first most important is timing
knowing when and where the damage is
going to occur and making sure you get
up your control strategies whatever you
choose to use out in a timely fashion
before the damage gets too severe once
wildlife develop a feeding habit it's
really difficult to break that but if
you can sort of know that hey my
blueberries are starting to get turning
color the sugar contents going up I
better get my netting on now before
those birds start feeding you can have
more success diversity is important you
got to know what different tools and
techniques are out there and some fine
combining tools work sometimes it
doesn't I'll share some data with you
about that persistence is really
important this is not something you do
once and walk away from to be successful
most of the tools and techniques we have
require continued often daily attention
in some cases to moving things around
filling gas generators to make sure
you've got electrical power so
electrical power to you in the door
making sure your batteries are up on
your solar powered units and then
monitoring you got to know what's
working when and where and what I'm
paying for wildlife control benef
kidding me is it worth it a lot of times
on particularly some bird date i'll show
you later on it probably doesn't pay for
what most of the growers are doing for
birth control except in certain
conditions where you've got low crop
yields most wildlife leaves sign to the
president's often easy to identify who
the culprit is like for example if you
can see the deer tracks up with in the
corn ear or deer damaged apple trees or
nursery crops are really easy identify
because deer have lower incisor an upper
hard palate they don't have upper and
lower and sizes like rodents so they
don't leave a clean bite when they bite
on something they leave this ragged torn
edge so it's usually pretty easy to
identify gear damage versus road damage
I mentioned the survey a deer damage to
agriculture in New York State I
partnered with Tommy brown and Dan
Decker folks with the experiment station
Farm Bureau a few years ago and we
wanted to estimate deer damage by a crop
type and region we wanted to look at how
growers were using Dec deer damage
permits that are available to help them
alleviate crop damage we want to compare
what the magnitude of deer damages
versus other wildlife damage that
they're seeing on their farms across the
state so we use the database farm
maintained by AG and markets to New York
egg statistics service and developed and
implemented a male questionnaire to 3909
farms across New York State we targeted
500 for agricultural region we end up
with 909 because there weren't 500 farms
on Long Island there are only 400 nine
so we hit all the farms on Long Island
our sample pool was twenty five thousand
four hundred ninety seven farms across
the state and to meet our criteria farm
had to have at least a thousand dollars
in reported sales and we include all
farms that were not exclusively like
bees and honey aquaculture in other
words you had to have a field crop
growing as some type that wildlife like
deer could potentially damage we got a
fantastic response rate compared to most
mail surveys nowadays
about a fifty percent response rate
we've got 1927 questionnaires returned
so we think we've got really good data
at least old data what the impacts were
we also followed up with a phone call to
a hundred non-respondents to look at how
dare damage differ at all from those
fifty percent of people who returned the
surveys and we found that by far the non
respondents had less damage and smaller
acreages farm so based on a formula we
down adjusted their raw damage reports
by thirty 1.5% to count for the non
respondent bias in the survey data so
again these are probably relatively good
statistics given the sample size that
we've got probably familiar with all the
new york state egg regions in New York
State I'm going to show you a few tables
and so data are broken down by
agricultural region and you'll see there
are some patterns that emerge terms a
total number of farms and sales again
for that full of 25,500 farms roughly
sixty percent of the farms reported
values at sales between 10 and 250,000
no big surprise there what was
interesting if you look at the
proportion of farms that reported more
than 250,000 dollars in sale the highest
percentage by far was on Long Island
with one in five farms reporting more
than 250,000 and sales and the lowest
percentage was in the southern tier with
only eight percent of farmers reporting
more than 250,000 sales and the big
farming regions or western New York
southern tier in central New York could
get no big surprise there we looked at
total estimated damage by deer that was
reported by the growers ended up being
almost 59 million dollars a year
statewide so we're talking about a
fairly substantial economic impact to
the farm industry in New York state by
far in terms of acreage and reported
damage twenty-three percent of that
total was in grain crops or thirteen
point six million dollars in losses if
you look combined alfalfa and other hay
crops you've got another twenty-four
percent another fourteen and a half
million
dollars in losses so if you take grain
and hay crop you're looking about half
the total damage in the state come from
those three crops so it's again a
significant economic impact for those
farmers and then you can even get down
to the specialty crops things like
grapes and Barry there's still a you
know one to two million dollars a year
in losses from wildlife we look at it
regionally break down the statistics by
far western New York has the highest
amount of damage with over 20 million
and then lower Hudson Valley
southeastern New York has the second
highest percent lossless a little over
14 and a half million dollars and again
those are our primary agricultural
regions in the state with some of the
better quality soils lots of firearms
lots of cropping systems they're trying
to relate that back to deer density it's
a guy take this a little bit with a
grain of salt but generally in western
New York where the highest damage is you
see the highest dear take a lot of these
while I think that units are averaging 9
to 16 dear taken per square mile in the
wildlife management unit so you got very
high dear dad sees here that overlap
with high crop densities and valuable
crops doesn't hold quite as true in
lower Hudson Valley a little bit lower
harvest rate but the issue in the lower
hudson valley is you've got a lot of
suburban development even though there's
a pile of deer there and there's a fair
amount of damage occurring a lot of
those deer aren't accessible to hunters
because of suburban sprawl and suburban
development so I average dear take per
square mile or but that doesn't mean
they're necessarily fewer dear there and
then not surprising the lowest end deer
densities in the state or in the
Adirondack ecoregion and so you tend to
see more lower levels of deer damage in
northern New York because you're
generally there you're just you know
maybe averaging less than ten year per
square mile and some areas up there we
ask growers on the survey what species
were one of the top three species on
your farm that are responsible for
wildlife damage and how much is it
costing you and eighty-three percent of
the growers across the state listed deer
in their top three species and we
attributed almost half of the total
wildlife damage that occurs stay
why cause bye dear so it had to be put a
lot of focus on deer and deer management
in our program thirty percent of rollers
listed turkeys about fifteen percent of
the damage was related to Turkey twenty
one percent listed geese 20 groundhogs
fifteen percent raccoon so this is sort
of the hit list these are the species
that are responsible for most of the
damage in agricultural situation and
list of turkeys and geese specifically
I'll talk a bit more about birds in
general in sort of the second half of a
presentation so what the Department of
Environmental Conservation do they've
got responsibility and authority for
deer management across New York State
unfortunately most of the laws and
regulation are written for managing deer
at broad scale landscape scale at the
state level or the wildlife management
that's deer tags or doe tags are issued
based on an estimating number of deer in
a specific wildlife management unit when
it gets down the farm level impact
there's really only two things that
landowners have available the deer
management assistance program and gear
damage permits and those are designed to
be landowner run programs and I'll talk
a bit more about each of those but by
far and away most of the effort in state
is at this level which really may not
help growers that are down at the
individual property level we ask growers
well the allow hunting on your farm and
what type of hunting do you allow and
not no big surprise eighty-three percent
of growers cross they do allow deer
hunting on their farm but two-thirds to
three-quarters only allow family friends
and neighbors that they know that's been
very consistent in many states surveys
that people don't like strangers on
their property they want somebody that
they know and they trust if they're
hunting deer and that main those folks
may not take enough dear to have any
real impact on crop damage only thirty
percent of farmers allow strangers to
hunt for the seventeen percent of
growers that don't provide any honey
access they cited problems with
liability and pass hunter behavior most
farms don't restrict sexa take of the
deer taken and that's a issue I think
we've got for education if you're going
to have impact on crop damage if you're
going to reduce to your
density you really got to harvest a lot
of female deer that's the growth
potential to hurt if you go take female
deer and you just you buck that herds
going to continue to grow because the
the doe's are the ones that are
producing the fonz every year only about
nine percent of growers require that
some dough's be taken on their farm and
opposite out six percent of growers only
allow bucks taken they don't want you to
shoot those which doesn't do a thing to
help with crop damage we ask growers are
you aware of the deer management
assistance program Dec has that have you
ever used those type of permits the way
the deer management assistance program
works is a farm land owners fill out an
application with Dec usually in
September and then Dec gives the
landowner additional doe tags antlerless
deer tags for use by hunters on their
farm during the regular open hunting
season so what they're doing is
encouraging hunters to come out of the
farm take more female deer hopefully
reduce population growth and hopefully
consequently deer damage only thirty-one
percent of growers or one responding to
our survey we're even aware that this
program existed and but of those that
applied for permits on average they got
seven half permits per farm and killed
5.6 deer per farm so again those folks
that get the permits do pretty well at
filling them and you'll see the growers
feel that these do help somewhat
alleviated damage the other type of
permits would call a deer damage permit
growers were more familiar with your
damage permits two-thirds a day and
heard of them but only twelve percent
applied for them deer damage permits
allow for a grower to kill deer usually
antlerless sometimes buck outside of the
normal hunting season so let's say
you're a strawberry grower and you've
got deer coming in in June that's just
hammering your crop and you're afraid
you're not going to get your crop out of
the field you can apply to dec for a
deer damage permit and shoot those deer
during June if you want to or any any
time of year outside the normal hunting
season also with a damaged permit you
can shoot at night you can use lights
you can use bait to attract deer let's
say shooting are you can do all sorts of
things that you can't do with hunting
that you can get written into it
damage permit we have been using those
the last three years here on campus to
try to alleviate some of our problems 15
what you've got to be a licensed hunter
having passed a hunter certification
course and you have to be at least 21
years old those are the only two things
that you don't have to be a farmer in
fact sometimes farmers will get the
permit you'll fill out a form of who
your designated agents are when you
apply for the permit and you could have
non farmers hunters friends who are
licensed and meet the requirement come
in and actually do the removal on your
farm you don't have to be the landowner
when the application submitted you list
your agents that are going to do the
shooting most farmers don't have time to
do a lot don't do it themselves they do
you know use their designated agents on
average again about eight and a half dep
were obtained per applicant seven deer
were killed so again most people are
filling these permits if they apply for
them and they feel they do some good so
just sort of the summarize the survey
part of this deer damaged agriculture
New York State is really important it's
a high economic impact particularly
Western in southeastern New York grain
and nursery Croft for the two highest
but if you had hey in there you've got
substantial forage crop losses most
growers allow hunting but most growers
don't put any restriction on the sexy
dear and i think you know we're talking
with with farm audiences and we talked
about deer damage we got to encourage
those farm land owners to take more
female deer the growers who used either
the dmap or the DDP program 79 d 2
percent of those growers and the survey
said they thought they released somewhat
successful in trying to reduce their
agriculture products well they solve a
problem no they're not going to solve a
problem but it might get you through a
cropping season for example if you've
got something like strawberry with a
very very narrow harvest window
intensive use of a deer damage permit
for a week or two might get you through
that harvest period we can get your crop
out of the field what do I recommend to
growers if you've got perennial crops
and you're in a high gear damaged area
things like tree fruits nursery crops
8-foot high fencing is the only thing we
know really works well expensive six
bucks a linear foot installed on average
so you can spend thousands of dollars on
a deer per fence but we know that works
if it's done properly electric fences do
work in some situations I like to go
with a baited electric fence on a single
strand of poly tape or poly wire get a
good of high voltage dear charger
something that's going to put seven to
ten thousand line volts out over the
line you can either use the peanut
aluminum foil tableaux peanut butter as
a senate raconteur i prefer using cloth
strips with a deer repellent some type
of odor in addition to the electric
enhances the effectiveness the electric
fence the way the peanut butter works is
a deer smells that peanut butter when an
approach to the fence and it touches
defense for the first time with its nose
or tongue and get seven thousand volts
through its nose that's a pretty good-
conditioner they don't full the fence
again after that happened usually and
the same thing with a repellent they
start to associate that repellent smell
with the electric fence and so sometimes
jelly I can spell that I might even go
near that thing but again the limitation
on electric fences is that they have
acreage size limit they tend to work
pretty well for small fields small
blocks under about five acres inside
sometimes five to ten acres are pretty
good but usually above 10 acres inside
dear we'll figure out the hell yeah I
can jump over that thing and there's
something good to eat inside they'll
learn that behavior and the electric
fences will fail eventually well talk
about a bit about bird management some
general bird management principle I was
part of a collaborative project with
Katherine lyndell from Michigan State
University and my grad student ID
Hendrix we had a USDA nifa especially
crop research initiative project funding
to look at multi-state impacts of bird
on through crafts in several states our
partners again with Cornell a Michigan
State we sort of led the program and did
a lot of the fieldwork we have partner
universities in the Pacific Northwest
and their fruit grow
region out there with Oregon State
Washington State Trinity Western and
folks from the USDA National Wildlife
Research Center in Colorado Fort Collins
or involved some of the survey design
and discussions on techniques to you
lots of different types of bird
deterrents out there everything from the
old scarecrow toes I live in a pie plate
you might see in somebody's backyard
Raptor model scare I blues mylar tape
all these things may or may not do any
good really depends on your cropping
system yet growers depend a lot on these
type of devices to try to reduce more
damage to crops basically just sort of a
general rule of thumb my experience with
a the hawk and OWL model that they tend
not to work at all I mean that's just a
given that the birds really figure out
pretty quickly that these things are
plastic and there no real danger small
areas we've seen some successfully the
bird distressed caller devices on small
areas on certain crops you'll see some
of the data I'll show you in a few
minutes they're not particularly
encouraging but we occasionally they
work the mylar flagging in the upper
right it's just a real highly reflective
flying that's tended to work pretty well
on some field crop situations
particularly with migrating geese not so
much with resident geese they've sort of
figured that out netting some people
consider a permanent fix I have my
question the way netting is done how
well that really works shooting can be
used in limited areas very site-specific
whether you can or can't and the same
thing goes for trapping say starlings
around a dairy farm or they're causing
contamination of foodstuff sometime a
limited trapping effort can do some good
our project objectives are looking at
things that influence an effective bird
damage management strategy and so we had
one group in the Pacific Northwest and
at the National Wildlife Research Center
that was looking at economics to try to
quantify cost of bird damage producers
consumer and how it affects regional
economies were still sorta in the data
analysis and writing stages on that part
we had another group of social
scientists that was looking at consumer
and marketing again those data are still
being analyzed you hope to get the paper
out here on that fairly soon and then we
had a group of us looking at the
biological side of thing landscape and
edge effects bird species and behavior
in affecting so different management
strategies and the last two are the
things that were farthest along on I
want to share some data with you today
we asked growers as part of the survey
in all those states in the New York
Michigan in the Pacific Northwest what
works and what does it in your opinion
you can see very clearly most growers
feel that the only thing that really
works is netting they claim netting is
very to moderately effective about
eighty percent of the time everything
else long this access has effective
streets of fifty percent or below most
growers have tried these things over
several year they realize well sometimes
they work sometimes they don't but they
continue to use them so again we want to
get some really hard data on how well
these different devices work for scaring
birds we had field research sites in New
York 96 unique farm where we collected
data in central and western New York we
did bird damage assessments looking a
percent damage the missing fruit we look
at edges versus interior block some
growers claimed all all the damages on
the edges well is that true we took a
look at that we did intensive bird
surveys look at what species were
present what's their foraging behavior
and then we had 52 additional farms in
Michigan that did the exact same
protocol so we could combine data from
New York and Michigan on the same craft
same year same time and do comparison
how things well things worked in two
different states in terms of damage
assessment we broke each block or filled
up in the five strata north south east
west edges and known that interior
stratum we selected for trees or bushes
in terms of blueberries 12 randomly
selected trees or bushes / stratum one
randomly selected branch / tree and then
counted all intact missing or damaged
fruit and we looked at sweet cherries
honeycrisp apples
blueberries and Pinot Noir wine grapes
so we did for focal crops on grapes
because they're on trellises are set up
with a little different we had a random
height and a random position along the
vine we pick a random height and
position and then we picked the cluster
closest to where ever that random high
position sell out we count all the fruit
on that cluster again damage missing
intact additional data we took for each
farm in second location where their
presidents a telephone wires nearby a
lot of growers say well it's those darn
wires the birds get their perch and then
they go down they steal my crop we want
to look to telephone lawyers really have
an impact other bird management
techniques surrounding land cover some
folks say is you know it's that dairy
farm next door attracts all the
starlings and now they're over here eat
my blueberries well is that true so
we've got good data on the land cover
characteristics around that still being
analyzed and look at number of plants
eat strata height and any special
additional data or notes we wanted to
take while we're in the field terms of
observations we use standardized point
counts to observers 15 minutes in the
block counting all the different bird
species that they saw we did it both on
the interior of the block and the
exterior of the block we did foraging
observations we get started with
stationary we're positioned the observer
where they could see on the edge and in
the block and just watch for an hour
what birds do you see pick a focal bird
followed as long as you can record all
the fruity touches eat consume and then
we did moving observations where
sometimes it's difficult to see what's
going on in a block particularly with
tall cherry tree and so we have observer
just walk slowly find a focal bird
followed as long as he could when that
birds gone find the next bird follow it
as long as you could to get focal
observations on who what they're
actually eating and damaging we look at
the sweet cherry data what really jumps
out at you is the percent fruit loss in
both sweet cherries and blueberries was
highest in 2012 you guys remember what
happened in 2012
what's that no what else could affect it
yeah late spring frost ninety percent of
the cherry crop sweet cherry crop in New
York was lost in spring 2012 a late
spring frost at a big chunk of the
blueberry crop of law so one of the
general principles is if you've got less
fruit on there because it's a bad year
for whatever he's a drought late freeze
then those of the years you've got to
pay attention to bird damage because
when you've got a low crop load the
percent fruit loss goes way up and we
saw that in 2012 and more normal
cropping years we didn't see a whole lot
very little damage and apples even
though apple cores are seeing the birds
eating our fruit the birds eating our
fruit we go out there measure we don't
see a whole lot in fact we did you only
did three orchards in 2014 and saw zero
damage we didn't see an ample damage by
bird wine grapes tend to be the most
consistent you know we're seeing about
three to four percent loss per year and
Pinot Noir wine grapes blueberries again
and sweet cherries you get good and bad
years again depends on the crop load we
look at again in the position to see
what growers are saying is true that
edges get more damage and interior and
we definitely don't see that trend in
any of the crops it looks like inside
and outside get damaged pretty much the
same the only pattern that we saw was
interesting whether we saw more damage
on the north and south end of blocks and
wine grapes so why would that happen
what's going on in wine grapes it would
increase bird damage on the north and
south ends what's that absolutely it's
the orientation of the trellises most of
the vineyards oriented nor self parallel
to the finger lakes because they're on
site slow that means the open end of the
roads are on the north south side that's
where you get your most intense bird
damage because it's easier for them to
get in the road from the north and south
in besides that we saw no pattern based
on position in the orchard we look at
the struct callers and hot kites and
fhe raptor effigy these are very
commonly used by growers throughout New
York and Michigan they think they do
some good so we want to see do they
really do any good at all what can we
measure so we group farms in the four
clusters of four so in that cluster of
four you'd have a block say a sweet
cherry block with a distressed caller a
sweet red block with a hawk aight a
sweet hairy block with both devices in
the field and then a control block and
our criteria is all those farms had to
be within 30 miles or in the same
population of bird because the birds are
very mobile we selected farms based on
the previous year's damage so we tried
to pick farm to add about the same
percent loss and similar block sizes we
set up the devices two to three weeks
before harvest and we position them at
least four rows into the block and we
had both deterrence on a block we set
them up on opposite sides from each
other and so then we actually collected
data to see how well these things worked
we move also moved two months a week
some people say moving a device adds an
element of surprise and increases
effectiveness so we switched positions
of devices once weekly and what we found
was these things didn't make a bit of
difference now it's unfortunate and in
fact the damage was highest where we use
both devices good so again growers think
these things work but they are wasting a
lot of time money if you look at the
control block except for this one
unusual New York farm actually the
controls suffered slightly less damage
than treated blocks and there was no
significant difference now when we did
the stats test across there had just
made no difference whatsoever put these
things up and in sweet cherries we also
came across the idea of using air
dancers and you might have seen these if
you used car lots these sort of silky
things that are air powered and wave
around we thought that all these things
got motion they're big maybe they'll
scare birds better in some of these
other devices so we set up site pairs
again with the same criteria and we had
one farm with a dancer one farm without
a dancer within 30 miles based on the
previous year damage in block size again
two to three weeks before harvest and we
move the dancers every two to three days
around the field so you can see sort of
the patterning every couple days it'd be
in a new spot we had to either these are
electric powered fans you have to run
them by either a electric cord which we
didn't have any cases or a gas generator
which means that the grower had to go
out there every day and refill the gas
generator because the generators that
run about eight or nine hours and then
they'd run out of gas but the growers
are willing to do that we looked at
sweet cherry damage and what we saw with
the dancers and sweet cherries a slight
benefit not significantly different
slightly less damage you still see lots
of farm the farm variability and again
that's very typical of bird am I that's
why you got to do a lot of farm if you
do one or two farms you're not gonna
learn anything you got to be doing 510
farm to get some sense of what works and
what doesn't blueberries again slight
difference with the dancers at about six
percent fruit loss on the dancer plot
little over eight percent control we
look at varies loss per day that was
marginally significant at point 05 so
again slightly fewer vloth but at those
type of differences that doesn't justify
the cost of running the things are
putting it out in the field of
blueberries where we did see a
difference was wine grapes and what we
saw was a about half the level of damage
where we had dancers of wine grapes and
it was significant at the point 0 1
level so these things appeared to work
relatively long wine grapes during the
first two years still a lot of farm to
farm variability and it doesn't work
everywhere here you can see on this farm
in Michigan the the dancer plot actually
had higher damage than the control why
said we don't know but again you just
see tons of variability in New York we
had more consistent results with the air
dancers and I think a lot of that has to
do with field side our blocks where we
were writing us our grape vineyards are
tended to be smaller on average than
when they
we're in Michigan our blueberry fields
also New York tend to be much smaller on
average than the typical Michigan
blueberry field so where you have
smaller block smaller sites these
devices are more likely to benefit you
in work we did a comparison between
dancers and control and in 2014 and use
to dances purse I you can see how highly
significantly differ except for farm a
everything was highly significantly
different so these devices really did
work on the wine grapes and the growers
have talked about we had one grower had
a naming contest for his device out by
his vineyard and his customers named in
mr. Pinot and so that's the you already
call these device he thought was a big
deal a little bit of marketing with it
we looked at other variables related to
bird damage and again the the telephone
wires kept coming up we couldn't see
anything significant in cherries of
grapes and we looked at blueberries
actually the blueberry field that were
closest to the telephone wire had less
damage and the reason we think is that
those tend to be much larger field so
the damage was more dispersed and so
they're good no strong relationship and
again we looked at netting impaired
plots Aria dancers and no dancers in
both areas were netting there was no
sipping significant difference and so
what we're seeing is birds are getting
through this netting with this larger
mess side we've seen that on long island
for years the birds are using the
netting for a perch and then they poke
their heads through and damage the
grapes through the netting so growers
are using a lot netting spending a lot
of money on it but we didn't see it
significant really reduced the bird
damage so who are the culprits these are
the common bird species we see in in
fruit orchards in New York and Michigan
and one of the take-home messages I want
to leave with you just because you see a
bird there doesn't mean that's the bird
that's causing the damage and we've got
data to back that up now we look at
sweet cherries in 2014 the most frequent
sighting by far in terms of number of
birds were american robins and years p
in Starling for number two we looked at
birds taking and eating
through America Robbins we're number one
and number of fruits consumed American
Robbins were number one that lines up
pretty well but we look at time spent
eating fruit European starlings even
though they're the second most frequent
bird they don't need a lot of fruit and
with cedar waxwings for number two in
terms of eating fruit and feeding on
spent time foraging on fruit yeah we
need to see very few cedar waxwings in
the vineyards but they do a lot of
damage so again growers may be missing
the culprit in these cases because
they're smaller less visible birds we
saw similar patterns in blueberry again
the most frequent bird we saw him
blueberries were American Robins
followed by Baltimore Oriole but when we
look at time spent eating fruit American
Robins ate very few fruits either time
or fruits consumed they were almost dead
last even though they were the most
common bird seen it was the Baltimore
Orioles and the cedar waxwings again
that spent most of the time consuming
the fruit so I see this with growers a
lot particularly with turkeys too they
say all the turkeys are damaging my my
vineyards well we really didn't see
turkeys taking grapes did some business
because they wander through and they're
big and visible the grower thinks that's
what's causing the problem it may not be
what we found is that in our field
trials in New York and Michigan at the
hawk kites and discussed collars and
even the combination to really didn't do
anything and past studies had pretty
miss results too we did find though that
the dancers showed some optimistic
results in grapes and in fact we had a
couple of our cooperating Greg glories
that wanted to buy the air dancers from
us after the end of the trial they were
they liked them so much they do take
intensive management you got to either
have electric power or you got to be out
there like I said moving around filling
that gas generator every day to keep the
windsock up and running nets didn't
significantly reduce berg damage that we
saw in the dancer site pair and we
actually saw a slightly lower bird
damage with blueberries related to the
telephone wires but again all the sites
of wires tend to be larger blocks I
think they just had less damage in
general
now nothing really related to the wires
so I just go back integrated wildlife
mango when you're working on farms are
working with a fire motor that's really
important to assess everything that's
going on what are the species causing
damage which crops are affected how many
acres what time what's the housing
density what are your neighbors like
lollies sound devices neighbors don't
like them and so again you're far more
rural you might have more options
available to you and then you've got to
go through you know what can I afford
and I would argue that in most years for
at least fruit crops in New York doesn't
pay to do any of this stuff except for
maybe air dancers and wine grapes but if
you get that bad crop year where you've
had a late freeze or you've had a
drought and the yield as though you
really need to do something that's the
area you want to do your bird management
because it's going to have an impact on
the percentage of fruit that you might
say and see it's important to reassess
too if things don't work why what can I
do differently there's something else I
haven't tried well there are options are
available to me a lot of these things
the growers put them in the field and
they walk away from and they just assume
they're working but if you don't assess
you don't know and very few growers go
to the trouble of actually looking at
fruit damage in in actual loss just want
to share website with you wildlife
control dot info their results of all
sorts of extension publications for
different species if you're interested
in that and also will eventually get
more data from our research projects and
links to papers and stuff up as we get
more of it written up but I appreciate
everybody's attention and be glad to
answer questions folks we have
showing kind of point out that matches
up with farms are from a farmer's
perspective you know I'm just curious if
you looked at the data in terms of
damage / 5 / fuel mindset yeah we
haven't really looked at it all at all
on a damaged for field basis or the way
growers react to it obviously you know
if you getting a relatively small fields
that are high value a lot of your income
coming and if you've got wild like
damage it could be more economically
painful that's for sure but we really
haven't looked at you know that in any
detail though we looked at the sort of
the broad trends broad statistics
yeah that's a really good question we
did try to collect bird species
information for the grave but when we
get our foraging observations both a
stationary and mobile we found so few
birds foraging there we we saw a bird
but we actually saw more flyovers
anything else birds that really never
fed and so we've had zero in terms of
foraging observation and grapes so again
the damage was relatively low compared
to the other clout and that may be
another reason why the air dancers
tended to work better there
industrial complexes and everything
or what's the like
for more common
you know what we call the resident or
the local breeding goose flock I
plateaued now but it plateaued at a
really high level and it's tens of
thousands of birds what we want above
what we want in New York State currently
if you go back a couple of decades there
were more what we call the migratory
geese the ones we all grew up with that
breed in canada winter in the Chesapeake
North Carolina but about a decade and a
half go that flip-flopped and so now
there are actually more resident birds
in eastern flyways local breeding bird
than migrants and they called all sorts
of problems and there are short distance
migrants they do migrate the only one
they have to so they're the ones that
breed locally they're here pretty much
year-round as well DD two things that
you'd open water which they have on cue
lake year-round and then eat grass so
the only thing that's going to drive
them out of here is if we get enough
deep persistence know that they can't
Ford then they forced to go south until
that snow melts so they're here most of
the year we've got a pilot goose project
in stewart park right now where we've
been using the tony ithaca goose
committee wanted to use only non-lethal
devices and I said told them right off
well don't expect the whole lot from
non-lethal bit we were able to at least
move birds out of Stewart Park using
firecrackers and radio-controlled cars
we got them out of the park and but they
didn't go far they went to the inlet and
cast Park which we expected what's that
and then terrify the park users we tried
to do at times a day very early in the
morning very late the evening not during
the middle of day when there are a lot
of park user and so we're be putting
together a report for the city of this
okay here soon on the goose efforts they
really need to start earlier in year
what we learned we banded 425 geese and
collared 200 adult since to her Park
this summer so I can see a goose wanting
rounds two apart for the big yellow
color that's when we put on and what we
learned was that most the geese that
caused a problem in stewart park in june
and july or not local breeding birds we
only found about 10 to 12 pairs that
actually had gods like a total of about
sixty gosling that were produced in and
around the park the rest of them are
what we call local won't my
there's so much water and grass around
Stewart park it's a perfect molting area
when they molt they drop their flight
feathers for five weeks and they cannot
fly so birds come in and they look for
places like Stewart park where they can
fly in drop those flight feathers just
sort of hang out feed defecate
everywhere Cree all sorts of havoc for
five or six weeks till they regrow their
flight for theirs in late July there on
off again somewhere else but we've got
to live with the mess during that the
mid summer when the parks got the
highest youth what the town and the City
need to do is move those birds out
before the molt they didn't do it and so
that's one of the recommendations going
to be before they drop their flight
feather that's when you need to do the
intensive hazing and non-lethal stuff to
try to get those birds out there get
them to molt somewhere else and I'm
stead of having 450 geese in stewart
park in late june hopefully we can get
it down to maybe 40 or 50 any other
questions I'll ask a quick question
about wild boar I know pro yes I did
have a min new yard looks like they're
no longer here but then you say
something about things they can do a lot
of damage yeah we're fortunate that DC
egg of markets and USDA Wildlife
Services saw a wild boar issues starting
to emerge and we did have some localized
breeding populations in New York there
was of them up on cortland onondaga
county line one in tioga county went up
in Clinton County in Northeast New York
and one on the Sullivan Delaware County
border and what USD while like services
staff got a contract to come in and do
eradication and USDA and Dec staff
really did a good job essentially we
eradicated breeding wild boars from New
York they're still get escapes every now
and then and there's new legislation
that's passed that farmers can't keep
wild boar on their farm I think of last
summer if I remember right and so
hopefully that will eliminate chances of
seeing wild boars in New York in the
future pennsylvania right across our
border still has wild boars and shooting
preserves and they escaped that was the
source of the tioga county population so
we're still gonna have to deal with that
okay
any last
any state programs that
their life here
yeah yeah we've actually done research
on campus with deer fertility control
and sterilization and we found after
about six seven years after the best we
could do with sterilization even
combining it with our campus to your
hunting program was to stabilize her
couldn't reduce it and so that's when we
went to our deer damage permit and
started to actually removing animals at
night over bait and we were able to cut
the herd and about half and two years on
a damaged permit and the other places
seen out we'd get a just finishing up an
experiment and ability to Cuba Heights
that's the fourth year the first two
years they couldn't get approval for
shooting so they hired in white buffalo
a contractor and we worked with white
buffalo and using Cornell veterinarians
we sterilize 99% of the female deer in
the village of Cuba Heights the first
two years and what we found was that
having that high proportion sterilized
for two years the population dropped by
thirty percent there was wasn't enough
immigration to replace the lack of fond
and then the village got approval for a
deer damage / meta kill permit the
contract with the white buffalo to come
back in the last two years white
Buffalo's actually done dear removal
crossbows at night that was approved by
village police and so with the two years
or removal now they dropped it another
forty percent so they have seventy
percent reduction in deer in the village
in cuba heights right now with that
integrated program question is will they
sustain it's a deer doing gear
management's like mowing the lawn guess
what it comes back you got to do it all
the time you can't wait a year of you if
you just you know give them a 23 year
break that's what to out reproduce you
they'll be right back there and you lose
all the call the games that you made
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu